the final general accounting rule that
we'll examine is called inclusion
exclusion and it is a straightforward
generalization of the sum rule at least
in the simple case of two sets that
we'll look at first
so we're going to look at the 604 two
example of applying inclusion exclusion
but let's begin by stating what it is so
the sum rule says that if you have two
sets a and B that are disjoint no
overlap between a and B then the size of
a union B is equal to the size of a plus
the size of B well that's obvious we
took that as kind of basic axiom but
what if they're not disjoint suppose
that a and B overlap and there's some
stuff in here that's the intersection of
a and B where there are points in common
what then is the size of a union B in
terms of similar things that we can
count and the answer is that the size of
a union B is the size of a plus the size
of B minus the size of a intersection B
now the intuitive reason for that and
it's not really very hard to make a
precise argument is that when you're
adding up the elements in a you're
counting all the elements in the
intersection once and then when you add
in the elements in B here a plus B
you're counting all the elements in the
intersection the second time the ones
that are in a minus B get counted once
the ones that are in B minus a get
counted once but the ones that are in a
intersection B get counted counted twice
so to get the right count I have to
subtract the size of a minus B so it's
only counted once in the total formula
and that's an intuitive explanation of
why inclusion/exclusion a formula holds
for two sets let's apply it and I'm
going to look at an example where we're
looking at digit permutations and I'm
going to look at permutations of the ten
digits 0 through 9 inclusive there's a
standard one where they're listed in
order and there is just a random seeming
permutation
of the digits 0 through 9 notice that
the 1 in 3 the 2 is sort of out of order
the rest are in order now what I'm going
to be interested in is those
permutations where certain patterns
appear so first of all let's noted that
the number of permutations we know how
to count it's 10 factorial I'm
interested in how many permutations have
a consecutive 6 and 0 a consecutive zero
and 4 or a consecutive foreign to in
other words two of the consecutive
numbers that appear in 604 - well the
first one does not
there's no 6 0 0 4 or 4 2 in this list
this one has a 4 2 so it would count as
one of those permutations that has
either a 6 0 a 0 4 or 4 2 because it's
got the 42 um here's one where you've
got a a a 2 and a 4 but that's not a 4
and a 2 and in fact there is no pattern
here of 6 0 0 4 4 2 so it's not one of
the permutations that I'm interested in
on the other hand here's one that's
doubly good this is a permutation that
has both a 0 4 in it and a 4 2 in it so
it would be of one of these permutations
of the kind that I'm looking for that
has at least one of the patterns 6 0 0 4
or 4 2 well if I let P sub X be the
permutations with the subsequence X then
what I'm really saying is that this one
with a 42 and it is in P 42 because it's
got the 42 pattern this one with a 0 4 2
4 2 and it is in the p 0 for a set of
permutations with the patterns e 0 4
intersected with the set of patterns
that have a 42 in it so that's what that
one illustrates so what we're really
asking for then is the union of three
things the union of P 60 p 0 4 and P 42
how many how big is the set of sequences
that have a 6-0 Union the set of things
that have a sick
zero for you knew the set of things that
have a four toe and as we saw
illustrated in the previous slide these
are not disjoint well I've been cheating
a little because in order to pick figure
out this one I'm going to need inclusion
exclusion for three sets instead of two
because it's in which is slightly more
complicated because I have a union of
three things that overlap and let's look
at that so what is inclusion exclusion
look like for three sets if I want to
know what's the size of a union B Union
C here's a Venn diagram that shows a
picture of a union B Union C with all
possible overlaps Illustrated there and
the formula turns out to be um you add
up a B and C you add up the size of a
the size of B and the size of C know now
that has the consequence that just that
sum of a B and C is counting this a lens
shaped region that is the intersection
of a and C it's counting it twice in the
a plus C term it's counting a
intersection B twice and it's counting
this lens shape which is C intersection
B twice so in order to get the sum right
I'm going to have to subtract oh one
occurrence of a intersection B 1 a
intersection C 1 B intersection C so
that those items are only counted once
in this sum and then in fact if you look
at this region here the sort of rounded
triangle region which is the
intersection of a with B and C that one
is actually getting counted three times
all three circles overlap it so when I
add in a and I add in B and I add in C
every one of those points there is being
added three times on the other hand this
rounded triangle shape which is counted
three times in the sum a plus B plus C
is being subtracted three times because
when I look at a intersection B on this
region and I subtract it I'm taking one
away from the count on each point there
and likewise with a and
Section C takes one away and B
intersection C takes one away leaving
the points in the rounded triangle in a
intersection B intersection C not
counted at all so if I'm going to get
the total count right so that every
point is counted exactly once I have to
add back in the intersection of a and B
and C so that's an informal explanation
of why v of how the inclusion exclusion
formula works for three sets we'll look
at ways to rigorously prove inclusion
exclusion for an arbitrary number of
sets shortly but not in this segment
let's go on and apply the inclusion
exclusion rule for three sets to the
example of digit permutations with the
pattern six zero zero four and four two
and the way to remember this is that um
the odd the the intersections of an even
number of sets occurred negatively the
intersection of an odd number of sets
occur positively and of course a single
set can be thought of as just an
intersection of one set with itself and
so it's also odd and occurs positively
alright um well now we can apply the
formula and say that um the set of
permutations that have a 6 0 and 0 4 and
a 4 2 is equal to the sum of the number
that have a 6 0 the number that have a 0
4 and the number that have a 4 2 - the
numbers that have two of the patterns um
- uh those that have all three patterns
and let's count these individual
intersections and sets of permutations
separately it turns out that each one is
easy to count which is a typical
situation why which is why inclusion
exclusion is Val valuable principle
because this thing that is harder to
count can be broken up into counting a
bunch of other things intersections that
are often easier to count and they will
be here so let's begin by looking at P
60 P 60 is the set of permutations which
consists of which of which have a 6-0 in
them
well to count them we can think about it
this way think of the patterns with a
6-0 in them as a permutation of nine
items the digits one through five and
seven through nine and a the object six
zero that you can place anywhere but
it's got to be lumped together so there
are really nine possible permutations of
these things um eight of them digits and
one of them is this pair of digits six
zero and the number of those
permutations is equal to the number of
permutations with the patterns six zero
so the answer is there are nine
factorial permutations with the pattern
six zero same of course applies to p 0 4
and P 4 2 on the the number of
permutations would be given two digit
pattern is nine factorial okay what
about P 60 intersection P 42 well you
can think of this is the same way you
can think of this as saying okay I've
got an object six zero I've got an
object for two and I've got the
remaining digits one three seven eight
nine to permute and the the the
sequences of of ten digits that contain
both a 6-0 and a four to correspond
exactly to permutations of the digits 1
3 5 7 8 9 and the object for 2 in the
object 6 0 now there's eight of these
things and so the number of permutations
of these eight things is 8 factorial
which means the size of P 60
intersection P 42 the number of
permutations of 10 digits that have both
a 6 0 and a 4 2 pattern is 8 factorial
now that's the case of an intersection
where these two things don't overlap
let's look at the case of P 60
intersection p 0 4 well if it's got both
a 6 0 and a 0 4 it actually is the same
as having a 6 0 4 so the intersection of
P 60 and piece of p 0 4 is the set of
sequences that have the patterns 6 0 4
and I count those in the same way I say
okay I've got an object 6 0 4 plus the
remaining digits 1 2 3 5 7 8 9 for a
total of 8 object
and the number of permutations of the
digits of the ten digits that have the
pattern 6:04 corresponds to the number
of permutations of these eight things
again eight factorial okay finally how
many permutations are there that have
all three patterns six zero zero four
and four to that of course is exactly
the same as the set of sequences with
the single pattern six zero for to the
four digit pattern and again we count
that by saying that it's the number of
permutations of the digits other than
six so four to six of them plus the six
oh four to object there are seven of
these and so there are seven factorial
permutations that have all three
patterns so that means that I can go
back to my inclusion exclusion formula
for the patterns that have one of the
Phyllis sequences that have one of the
three patterns six zero zero four and
four toe and plug them in so I get three
nine factorials for the first sum of
three terms the intersections we all
figured out each of them were of size 8
factorial so I'm going to subtract 3
times 8 factorial and this last term we
figured out was 7 factorial well I can
think of 3 times 9 factorial as 9 times
8 times 3 times 7 factorial and this is
3 times 8 times 7 factorial and I wind
up
you
seventy two thousand seven hundred and
twenty that's how many permutations of
the digits 0 through 9 there are that
have one or another of these three
patterns turns out that's about 27% of
the 10 factorial permutations of 0
through 9 so that's the significance of
this of applying this disjunction of
constraints this union of having either
6 0 0 4 or 4 2